that you want yeah I got my pen you're
looking good today Vinnie thank
you did you ever think you
make Victory I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David G values contagious this
world of entrepreneurs we get no value
to haters run homie look what I become
I'm I'm the
one okay we are live Rob what episode
are we on today uh 348 pbd podcast we
got uh
obviously uh quite a few stories to
discuss last night there was a trump
Town Hall okay with Fox then there was a
CNN debate the santis again against
Haley no V uh uh right after Christy
announced he's stepping away but there
was a hot mic of him saying certain
things about Nikki Haley which we'll
talk about the debate between the santis
and Haley was very weird because it
looked like they flat out couldn't stand
each other did you see the ending of it
I I didn't so you know when they did the
uh Hillary Clinton and and the the Trump
debate and then at the end can you say
one good thing about uh Trump or Hillary
and then both of them actually gave one
good thing about and they couldn't stand
each other Trump's family is what she
applauded Trump's family kids and she
was very respectful about the kids and
then Trump said Hillary's doesn't quit
she's a fighter and you could tell it
was actual compliments Haley did not
give a sincere compliment it was super
snobby did you hear it did you hear did
you watch the entire debate or no I did
I did okay yeah so we'll talk about that
one right there yeah she's part of the
disc Camp it's unattractive it's
unattractive we'll talk about that she
she said she hit her nerve the Santa
says you're making excuses it was great
and then at the same
time uh uh aside from all the stuff
going on Pat M Pat McAfee Adam and I had
a very nice little back and forth on
what's going to happen with Pat McAfee
wait till you see the decision I mean
you at this point if you're watching the
podcast I'm sure you already know what
he did we're going to play the clip
we're going to have some commentary on
it and as if there's not enough drama
already in sports Stephen A Smith and
Jason Whitlock go at it because Jason
Whitlock call Stephen A Smith the Kevin
Hart of sports TV it's Jason whitlock's
the guy that was Jason Whitlock is a
sweet man Stephen A Smith who never even
mentions his name ever to the one
running across our driveway trying to
avoid us Jason wock is the guy the
fearful show he has a show called
fearful he's so fearful fearful or Fe
fear it's Fearless but you know there's
a lot of fear involved Fearless also
known as scaredy cat fearful called
we'll talk about that okay anyway so
that's a inside joke between us but look
you guys brought it up you call that
Stephen A we'll talk about it few other
stories uh aside from that uh last night
uh uh SEC apparently approved the
ETF uh uh uh what do you call it the my
say is correct let me let me pull this
up here right now yeah that's right
approved the the ETF for Bitcoin and
Bitcoin went up slightly but there's
there's some other things we can talk
about with this SEC authorizing the ETF
we'll talk about that um California
lawmakers ready for this considering
Banning tackle football for kids under
the age of 12 okay all my four kids
would qualify for that including
Brooklyn this means Brooklyn cannot play
tackle football that's what that's what
would happen in California
discriminatory and I watched this video
yesterday you you were walking the
streets of New York I don't know if you
saw that you were in the streets of New
York and then you step in this thing and
it drops I saw what the je and then you
looked below and these the Jewish people
that were dancing like unbelievable to
the point where you started dancing I
was such the Rhythm was ridiculous so
maybe we'll show a clip of what's going
on MIT you indoctrinated there it is
okay Hunter Biden comes up with uh uh
three members of the was it Gambino or
the the genev I don't know which family
it was but hunter rden shows up with a
couple Mobsters fouchy had a 7-hour back
and forth and he was uh uh apparently
rumor has it he was wearing
flipflops because he kept fliply
flopping flippy FL Rob am I saying it
correctly kept going flip flop flop flop
flip but we'll talk about that and then
here's a political story talking about
that the Epstein list and uh is a
farri uh uh uh is obsessed with sex
trafficking political says why is the
far right so obsessed with sex
trafficking and I love what Chris CUO
said to somebody on Twitter which we'll
show here in a minute as
well uh what else do we got going on
here A bunch of did you guys hear about
the the new podcast that's getting
started what it's going to be a
legendary podcast here no so Nick Sabin
Pete Carroll and Bill b start a podcast
what are they going to call it we're
out we're out out bro peace can you
imagine if they pull up a cat Williams
and talk about all the players like
you want to say about me do you
remember that one time we did this and
you did that no but I heard they were
going to call it coaching yeah like
coaching Sabin stepped away per uh uh sa
actually retired Pete Carroll stepped
away and Bill bich rumor has it it's
going to be done uh I think it's mutual
separation there Charlemagne the God
trashes Biden and then indirectly ends
up trashing Trump more saying we don't
really have a a candidate Ray EPS
sentenced to one year's probation for
his role in the riot I wonder why that
is and $500 Don Lemon is officially
bringing his show to X it's lemon Pat
forgive me say it right but Don Lemon
bringing his show to X which by the way
I'm actually really excited to see what
he's going to do let me tell you why
because it's no longer within the No No
I because some people still are within
somebody right I'm going to be curious
to know what he's going to be doing what
he's going to be saying very much
looking forward to it 10 15 years ago he
said some stuff that was pretty powerful
and it was so direct when viral maybe a
part of that comes out I don't know
we'll see X announces peer-to-peer
payment services and then uh Chinese
billionaire is second biggest foreign
owner of us land and uh Melania Trump's
mom uh uh amalah uh died at the age of
78 and this entire time everybody was
wondering if you Trump you know all the
issues marital all that stuff this is
actually something that was going on so
it's always she's the same age as Trump
which I find a little uh interesting
well maybe you can comment on that the
Mother-in-law yeah saying is that like a
is are you saying it from a standpoint
of a hero status like that's facts
around here I got no opinion can
St daddy thing going on I felt an
element saying they're the same age all
I'm saying okay now let me tell you what
we're doing gang here's what we're doing
man was on before we get into it let me
go to uh talk to you about man so we got
an internal contest going on last week
again uh Tom had 31 minuts in a single
day 12 calls 19 texts I respond to all
the mans in audio and in the last I want
to say 6 weeks I've done nearly 200 mans
all 100% I respond in audio uh it's my
voice when I'm responding back you're
doing a bunch of calls this guy's doing
a bunch of calls with young men that are
wanting you know advice and life and
finance and how to change your life
going from maybe the party side to
getting your finances in order uh uh and
then Tom you're doing a bunch of things
with that but there's an internal
contest going on as well folks look at
this as election time okay you got time
you got Vinnie you got Adam who do you
love the most Show Your Love by
connecting with them and do a video call
with them text them send a video
response from that you're GNA get Adam
Vinnie and Tom In the Flesh responding
back to you last time I did this man
call out I did it at the end of the
podcast we got a lot of them but this
time I'm doing it at the beginning
because there's a contest friendly
contest this thing's going to get a
little bit nervous here on guys and
girls because I announced the right
before Christmas I think it was around
Christmas or a day before Christmas
whoever from that day gets to 500 mans
it doesn't matter if it's a call or it's
a video if it's a text any of these
three guys by the way if anybody else
wants to participate you can also
compete because we got a bunch of other
new people on man that are growing
rapidly I'll make a video about it today
whoever gets to 500 gets a $2,000 suit
from me and they're all fighting for it
Tom's in the lead right now at 136 130
second place is Vinnie right now with 65
oh snap but Adam is only behind you by
two with 63 can I address my constituent
give it 20 seconds hi everybody I'm
Vincent oana Tom's Rich Adam's rich I'm
not please man man I want to win please
help thank you support a brother take a
lesson from Tom this is how bad Tom
wants to win Slash's prices in half it's
a BOGO onck thanks
Tom it is what it is Tom I have a
witness with Pat I did not do thato with
Tom please by the way by the way you
already seen it guys I I'm look I'm
doing the the politician hey Rob do you
have the link below so people can
download it put it in the chat as well
if you can and put it in the description
folks go download it or take one of
these QR codes whoever you want to go to
take the QR code go to them ask them a
question you know who I'm rooting for
who's that I'm rooting for Vinnie I'll
tell you why Tom's got enough money he's
already playing the game he slashes
prices in half by the way if you want
advice from the bis do super cheap for a
great advice you can go the website Adam
lives.com because I did not do that it's
great you know
what listen you know what you're getting
from pbd the goat like whatever the
price is it's worth the price of
admission Tom is slashing ADV his viice
half off you're you're Des don't need
the money what I'm telling the people is
they're they're getting a great deal I
just got my Bo I'm rooting for Vinnie
thanks buddy if you want to be cheered
up in your lifein this I'm watching
right now to see who's going to get just
during this call here today but anyways
go download the app it's a place I love
communicating on man that's the number
one app I check when I wake up in the
morning all these influencers every week
we're getting hundreds of influencers
joining man right now and what happens
is on Instagram and on LinkedIn people
don't respond 95 98% of the time nobody
responds back to you at men they do
because I believe you need to pay for
somebody to respond respond back to you
they have busy lives if you want
somebody to get back to you pay for it
and they will and it's a guaranteed way
of getting people to respond and that's
what we did man the whole story with man
for me was years ago a lawyer I did a
7-minute call with this guy charged me
for 30 minutes upset me I asked the
lawyer can I pay you by the minute he
says no lawyer charges by the minute I
said one day I will develop a website or
an app that I get to pay people by the
minute this is why we call the app do
you have a minute to connect let's man
we're going to turn man into a verb it's
going to be in the dictionary let's man
can I can I say what just just to let
everybody know cuz I hear a lot of uh
Vinnie why don't we just Cameo this is
not Cameo and just a quick thing um you
guys know who I am comedian funny crazy
people call me the CW I I don't even
like saying it I'm a coincidence
theorist but I everything from I make
people laugh to telling them jokes to
yesterday I prayed with a dude I'm
crying emotional about wow dude it this
thing is isn't it the greatest
experience rewarding because you're
making an impact right one this by way
this isn't like I'm saying this isn't a
happy birthday John I mean you can get
that if you want but this isn't what and
and be honest though every once in a
while like there is an element to uh
like people ask to see your tattoo shirt
off I was no oh hold on hold on guys hey
hold on can I go back hey everybody if
you want to see me my shirt off my neck
I'll do it anyways let's get right into
it guys we got a lot of topics to cover
uh uh vote by man Tom put your phone
aside put your phone down what he just
lowered his price again
$8 all right let's go first story Pat
McAfee we talked about it yesterday
right we sat there and we said Pat
McAfee he's not going to Cave it's ESPN
or Pat McAfee I don't think he's going
to Cave I think ESPN is the person with
what do you call it the example I gave
with there the people that they're going
to do this and they're going to do that
well the story comes out 24 hours later
and guess what folks what happen Aaron
Rogers will no longer be a guest on the
Pat McAfee show for the remainder of the
season as confirmed by Pat McAfee who
expressed there would be a lot of people
who are happy with that myself included
to be honest with you I am happy that
he's not going to be in my mentions
going forward which is great news during
the final appearance on the sh and
Rogers primarily discussed his ongoing
feud with Jimmy Kimmel and his
controversial viewpoints on Co Pat
McAfee remaining loyal to Rogers
acknowledged some of his thoughts and
opinions do piss a lot of people off off
McAfee also expressed relief saying I am
pumped that we will no longer be in
every single Wednesday of my life which
it has been the past few weeks Rob can
you play this clip and I think go past
the first 20 seconds to the announce
right there play it from right there go
ahead included to be honest with the way
it ended
got and myself included to be honest the
way it ended it got real what we do know
is the guy that stopped by yesterday
because it's quite a conversation little
bit yeah little bit now very usual
not like that the uh so Aaron Rogers
Tuesday season 4 is uh done
yeah that's fine there's going to be a
lot of people that are happy with that
myself included to be honest with the
way it ended it got real loud and uh
real loud I'm happy that that is not
going to be my mentions going forward
which is great news we're a conversation
show people are having conversations we
live in a country that has freedom of
speech but also you're going to have to
deal with the consequences of your
freedom of speech so what I'm saying is
we've given a lot of people who've been
waiting for us to fail a lot of ammo and
things to attack us for over the last
week and we would love to get back to
the point where we just move on and
continue to silence all the haters over
here who can't negotiate as good as I
can all the people over here who can't
create a show as good as us and all the
people up here who are just going to
always be here and they're going to
hustle and do their thing which I
respect but we need to do that and that
is our Focus that is our goal and Aaron
Rogers is a Hall of Famer four time MVP
he's a massive piece of the NFL story
whenever you go back and tell it he will
be a huge part of it we are very lucky
to get a chance to chat with him and
learn from him some of his thoughts and
opinions though do piss off a lot of
people lot of people and uh I'm pumped
that that is no longer going to be every
single Wednesday of my life uh which it
has been for the last few weeks on
Friday obviously I threw us into the
fire as well forever stand by that
everything else though like just can't
do that and not what we want to be known
for and I'm also pump that I have to do
these types of talks anymore so with
that being said sports are alive right
now what do you think about that dude
just who was the guy that was talking to
him Tom who was the guy that they were
mentioning that Norby
Williamson will what do you I think nor
the corporate bureaucrat guy I think
after that last time the video that we
saw they came in there and they said Hey
listen you are going to do this you are
going to say this and that is that after
he did that big ass spe speech about how
he's in charge and he's the man and all
that I I I don't even watch this show
but there's I lost so much respect for
him cuz he didn't stand his ground
period Adam look let's just go over the
facts right because we're going to have
a lot of opinions on this who owns ESPN
right Disney Disney right ABC Disney
we've talked about this trying to sell
ESPN Disney uh we uh we've talked about
this a million times where the biggest
Advertiser on Legacy Media mainstream
media is who big Pharma a month ago we
had a conversation with Colby uh
Covington Colby Covington less than a
month ago where he basically called out
tra uh Travis Kelce we see what's going
on with him and Taylor Swift he's been
bought sold paid for by fizer that's
done he said he made $20 million when
any other advertising basically agenda
would have been closer to $5 million
it's a pay for play pay forplay
situation going on with Legacy Media
mainstream media Disney ABC ESPN fizer
we all know they're ined together in
comes Pat McAfee hey I'm R from tumble I
don't wear no sleeves I kick ass for a
living I do what I want Aaron Rogers all
right cool he just got a taste of what
it's like working in mainstream media I
don't know if he actually stands by
these comments doesn't stand by these
comments what I do know is that whatever
relationship he had with Aaron roders is
now defunct if you're Aaron Rogers how
are you looking at Pat McAfee being like
yeah that's my boy I don't think so
so we had a conversation yesterday what
it would take for you to sell your your
soul or to sell your boys down the river
for some things that you stand for
100% you're not going to cave for that
so what I'm I'm reading the tea leaves
here turns out Pat McAfee cares about
the money that he does more about his
relationship with Aaron Rogers that's
clear yeah so and it turns out that
maybe they weren't as good as friends as
he want as as we maybe perceived them to
be so the bottom line is this $85
million when you made a couple million
bucks in your day will make anybody take
a second thought huh huh huh and it's a
lot easier to stand there and say I
wouldn't do that I wouldn't do this go
ahead look at a look at a blank check
for $85 million and all you have to do
is sign let me know when you're in that
situation and that's when we'll find out
who are said but Pat MCA the last video
that we saw Tom didn't he say he goes I
have control of my show I have creative
control whatever he wants to talk about
how did that change somebody had to tell
you don't have creative control when you
work for ESPN you work for Disney and
they have their Wok so whatever the he
says is one thing what does the contract
say what does the dotted line say the
bottom line is this you sign a contract
for $85 million to literally do what we
do some people are going to have to tell
you yeah you can't say that can't do
this especially when it comes to the
fiser situation cuz that's the Crux of
the situation don't be fooled by the
Epstein Jimmy Kimmel Aaron Rogers thing
this comes down to Big Pharma and fizer
yeah when you take a look at these
contracts two things can be true at the
same time pat mcafe saying this is my
show I'm the producer I make decisions
on my guests that could be absolutely
true but in every one of these contracts
nowadays there are moral interpreter
Clauses such as he can't get himself
into some terrible situation that uh
like show up on the epsteen list and
that puts you know um the ESPN brand at
Peril he can't do that also in the
contract there's going to be statements
about inflammatory statements and things
that are over the top like he brings
down a bunch of people that are pro this
or Pro that that are just completely
inflammatory there's going to be Clauses
in there that says hey you control your
guest you control that but if this all
that happens this is here and I think
ESPN you know dropped the dime on Pat
and said Pat we got to talk he says
listen you know Aaron Rogers this this
this and this controversy great it's
good for Ratings but when he crosses the
line over here we can't have this we
can't have that we we can't do this we
got to we got to pull them off the show
that last segment there were so many
things packed in that lasagna had so
much stuff in it that we just can't deal
with and I bet there was some Screaming
I bet there was a big thing going on in
a conference room and I bet McAfee
didn't want to do it but then it appears
that he caved and the opening of a
segment is this careful thing where he
lays it out and I Adam I think a lot of
what you just said is right but I think
a lot of this you said on the line that
is dotted a lot of this is already in
the contract so here's here's my
thoughts guys let let me tell you when
you're around in business for a long
time you trust fewer people okay why do
you trust fewer people because you you
let me let me restate that you trust
fewer people's words Everybody Talks few
people do I remember one time I go to
earlier stage when we're growing and
this is
2008 uh 2009 uh I want to say March or
something like that and and I'm putting
an event together somewhere around that
date I'm putting an event together and
at this event this girl gets up on stage
and it's probably oh wait this girl gets
up on stage and she is the spokesperson
on these other Five Guys that got me a
nice little booklet and 15 people paid
for this thing and it's pictures and
stories of everything she's up on the
stage and she's say let me tell you you
father Li 10 minutes she's in tears this
is on video by the way oh man like we
have it in our uh what call in our
archives a week later she leaves me for
$30,000 and a BMW wow and goes and
becomes a direct competitor to us okay a
week later two weeks later and people
watching us who know who she is they
know who she is like this boom she did
that fast forward we got another
guy let me tell you I I'm forever I'm a
forever I'm about everybody eats and I'm
about this and this and that really I'm
a ride or die type of guy bro awesome so
we're working with this guy boom boom
boom boom boom all of a sudden one small
little offer $100,000 he's gone it
didn't take a lot of money he's gone
right and then you have people who
behind closed doors get offered millions
of dollars lifechanging money and they
don't Flinch okay and I have those
stories as well in the company and those
who don't do that are rewarded longterm
those who do then they're going to be
doing that for the rest of their lives
and guess what someone's going to know
in the marketplace you're going to be
driven by money no problem as you age in
life you'll realize eventually you can
have the money you can have all that
stuff what matters the most is who do
you spend time with on Christmas Day who
do you spend time with on 4th of July
who comes to your house with their kids
who wants to have a friendship with you
who do you want to have a strong
friendship with relationship with and if
you do you got to pour into it and and
you got to show that values are more
important than money I remember one time
um this is
200 what's peak of covid
20 this is 20 uh uh 21 is what it is and
I'll tell you the month of it it's
probably August or September and we come
after the event and uh uh uh wherever we
are and uh we have a board meeting with
me and they're sitting there saying Pat
with everything that's going on right
now with covid you need to send
nurses to offices with vaccines to get
all the agents vaccinated so they don't
get covid I said I'm sorry yes then I
noticed two people teamed up on me on
that call and it was two specific people
that they're saying well and by the way
I love these guys till today I love
these guys and they say well listen if
you go to such and such private Equity
company in New York if you go to this
company and this you have to give your
card and you have to show that your
vacin it it's very normal with these big
companies and if we want to be big we
got to follow the leader of the big
companies I said yes not not going to
happen well think about it for 3 hours
the entire board meeting with board
members maral's in the room everything
was about us getting everybody in the
company vaccinated how do you think that
call and by the way just so you know I'm
not rich at this time mhm I'm paper rich
yeah but I don't have a few hundred
million dollar I don't have the the the
cash that we're talking about that
hasn't happened yet there's a big
difference between being paper rich and
between cash rich Tom you know the
difference right there's a big
difference there right because you're
like man I got a lot of equity but this
thing can be lost tomorrow so you may be
able to compromise because you're
worried what if you lose the money right
there's a big difference between you
have $85 million and it's already
contract G in the bank anyways I say no
it's not going to happen we want you to
consider this it's not going to happen
finally I make a video and the video I
send out everybody on that week people
know they're like oh wow P what's Pat
say in this video said guys here's all I
ask of you if you choose to get the
vaccine
don't judge them if they make that
choice that it's proper for them I said
my dad's 79 years old he got the vacine
and he's getting the boosters my nanny
she got the vaccine she got the boosters
we chose not to get it no one in our
family judges anybody if you get it you
will not be judged by me if you don't
get it you will not be judged by me
period And I was a message that went out
I'm not sending nobody to go give you
shots so guess what happens long term
you get to trust who you want to be in
business business with now if in life I
do agree with Adam there are certain
people that are Solo people that it's
all about them and it's about their
money it's about them you know what I
yeah of course if it's about you you're
going to make those decisions there's
solo players in life there's team
players in life this decision was made
he caved Pat McAfee caved in regards to
how their relationship's going to be
moving forward or not I think Aaron
Rogers still follows Pat McAfee on
Instagram and there's still that going
on I think even Aaron Rogers made a
comment about it Rob what is this your
show me do you want me to read this this
is Pat McAfee's tweet last night he's
saying that Aaron Rogers isn't banned
from the show it's just his segment
always ends at the end of Aaron roders
football season the jet season ended
last week so this is I know about this
but that's not the point A lot of people
are saying well you're not saying this
pad you're kind of misrepresenting no no
he said I'm kind of happy because
freedom of speech has consequences and
you said something so you this is
flip-flopping no no I'm not buying this
I'm not buying this the specific words
are I'm kind of happy we're no longer
dealing with that those are the words
from you I'm happy we're no longer
dealing with that and and that is a form
of you not wanting to talk about that
okay would McAfee I was kind of happy
Rogers wouldn't be back on the show
because of the drama it caused yeah okay
cool then that's what you want to do
that's what you want to do but for me
Aaron roders gained a ton of respect
jokovic didn't play in Australia Open
think about this for a second for you
you're like oh if it's money Del cave
that could have been the difference of
him being known as the greatest of all
time because he needed one more mass one
more what do you call it Grand Slam to
win and what if he gets injured and he
never wins a grand slam again so you
mean to tell me not taking the vaccine
was more important than never being
known as the goat you know what jokovic
said yes that's what jokovic said have
you seen what he said on the clip about
the vaccine where they asked him a
question why don't you take the vaccine
jovic have you seen the clip what he
said on this yeah no his position was
just like because it's my choice yeah
and I want to be respect of My Health
Choice I don't think I need it go ahead
but well I want to get I'm going to ask
you a question but um cuz I want to know
where you think the odds are on who this
is on right this is on ESPN this is on
MCA this is on Rogers this is on Kimmel
like an odds type situation I want you
to maybe uh break that down but when I
say that everybody has a price I stand
by that but it depends on what the
causes and where you stand on this what
do I mean everything in in life the most
everything comes down to relationships
and friendships if you're friends with
somebody and you're loyal to somebody
you will there's no price you won't cave
but if you're not loyal to somebody and
there's no friendship and there's no
relationship there if it's not as as uh
connected as you think it is then you
might cave I'll give you an example you
brought up the insurance industry I Met
You in 2012 I've been in the industry
since 2006 y my firm is the best in the
country at doing this One Thing Called
Life Settlements I've been to a million
different nabas meetings fcas Aus every
single of these meetings Pat for 17
years at every single one of these
meetings I get recruited hey man you're
the best at what you do you're so good
at people what would it take for you to
come work with us 17 years do you know
what company I'm still at 17 the same
freaking company okay and that's and
that's when I didn't have money and when
I have money when I didn't have money
when I just started to make money 2011
I'm a grooms in the Kardashian wedding
with my best friend Chris humph right
long story with that I didn't have money
at the time dude I don't know how they
get my number I don't know how this
happens I'm getting hit up by TMZ by E
by you name it dude nobody has to know
we'll give you 50 Grand take a picture
at the at the wedding phones weren't
allowed this in 2011 there you go there
you see me clean shaving saws right
there no glasses I'm not the
seven-footer in the back they offered me
50 Grand per photo go ahead yeah 50
Grand per photo what did I say no this
is my best friend I'm not going to throw
him under the bus and completely taint
our relationship for 50 Grand or 100
Grand not worth it so to leave
the company that helped me get started
in this hell no for a couple more points
to throw my best friend under the bus
for 50 Grand hell no and I can give you
list after list after list whether it's
Keith and the the NTI stuff that I do
whether it's Adrian and the Loyalty I've
had with him can I tell you something
I'm saying is everyone has a price based
on the relationship that they're going
to have to user yeah but but it's but
it's relationship that's one element
you're right the other part is also
values and principles if the value of
freedom of speech is not of value to you
you'll compromise it no doubt Aaron
Rogers said freedom of speech is not a
top three value to me no problem
entertainment is more important to him
than freedom of speech by the way go die
on whatever Hill you want to die
on my no exactly but you but you know
what this you you you brought something
up to me to to think about and I want to
transition into another story cuz we got
a lot of things to talk about is the
following who just part ways which which
big name and big platform just part ways
two months ago which name we talked
about on the podcast twice no John
Stewart and apple think about that can
you pull up the story John Stewart and
Apple so check this out in a way I
actually respected that decision yeah
you know why cuz you know what John
Stewart said he's not compromising no
bro that and I'm not a John Stewart guy
neither am I politically I I I think
he's funny I think he's very effective I
think sometimes he panders but I like
him right I like John Stewart Daily Show
hasn't been the same since he left play
that much question about it but watch
what he says he walks away from Apple TV
show after dispute over Ai and China
episodes you know what John respect
Bingo okay even though I know what he's
going to say politically he's going to
trash Trump he's going to trash a lot of
capitalism he's going to you know do all
this stuff and you know there's nothing
wrong with the element of social and all
this stuff I have so much respect that
the guy is not willing to say no you
can't tell me not to talk about Ai and
China and Rogers I'm sorry Pat McAfee
said nope I'm sorry I'm choosing this
over me choosing Aaron Rogers and FYI
the only time we've ever talked about
Pat McAfee on our podcast and by the way
he's a phenomenal Entertainer okay I
know people that work with him at bar
stool they tell me some Intel about how
it was to work with him I know people
who work with him at I think it's
FanDuel or whoever he was with uh uh uh
and and I got messages about what that
relation I'm talking about like in in in
in in people and they were kind of like
some people say they were kind of happy
that he's no longer with them with
FanDuel and he's not ESPN here's what
you can't deny about Pat McAfee he's
able to get eyeballs he's super
entertaining but here you look John John
you can't talk about Ai and China I'm
sorry Apple I don't give a that
you're a $3 trillion company I'm walking
you know what John boom I don't have to
agree with you I salute anybody that has
values and principles that they're not
willing to compromise more power to you
bro for doing that that's all I'm saying
mcafe still going to do well mcafe still
going to excel mcafe is still going to
bring a lot of eyeballs to them it's
just not my cup of tea that's all it is
uh and by the way I I think the
likelihood of Rogers coming back on next
year the following year he's probably
going to have him back on but they're
probably going to have a conversation
and say the only thing I ask of you is
the following and Rogers is either going
to say yes or no that's what I think is
going to happen I don't think it's like
they hate each other screw this guy F
him he doesn't have that kind of
personality to hate it's just I disagree
with what you didn't stand for let's go
to the next story all right so next
story uh do we want to go into uh uh uh
Rob which story do we want to go into
based on what uh the poll is telling us
the Trump Town Hall from last night so
why don't we do the Trump town hall and
then we'll go into uh do you have any of
that stuff here Rob as story or no we
just openly talk about it just openly
talk okay sounds good so Trump Town Hall
uh uh happened with Fox uh right off the
bat it was Brett Bear and what yeah and
I thought it was great and by the way I
have to tell you I watched the whole
thing and he seemed more presidential
than I've ever seen him I think he was
very calm collected gave his answers
likable the delegates that like I'm for
him or I'm for the santis I'm in the
middle well I hope I win your vote it it
came across as a very much of a he
looked cool and relaxed he looked cool
and relaxed for me to say that you know
it's true what you think about it go for
it dude I got to tell you Trump's
growing on me you know it's you heard
here first well I think I think I'm a
good indicator of where the country is
let me unpack that do it four years ago
if you asked me what I thought about
Trump I'd say no freaking way this guy
but
every election is the lesser of two
evils that we've been saying that for
the last decade well this that at this
point in Trump's career I think he
genuinely is like look I came into to
office I'm going to drain the swamp I'm
going to build the wall I'm going to
lock her up he made all these promises
and he realized that some of those
promises actually weren't going to be
get done and but he also realized that
the swamp is real that the Deep state is
real that the mainstream media agenda to
silence him is real and I don't think
really really knew what he was up
against in 2016 and I think in 2020 with
the help of the Wuhan flu he had the
double-edged sword with Wuhan and
mainstream media coming up against them
January 6 we can put aside but I think
now when he looks at you talk about
Legacy and where he's at he's like look
I tried to do a job you guys screwed me
over I want the job back do I have a
little Vendetta do I have a little
Vengeance sure we'll put that aside I'll
be a dictator on day one I'll shut down
the Border I'll drill baby drill but I
think at this point genuinely genuinely
he knows how Washington Works he knows
what the swamp is he'll hire hopefully
the right people that won't try to
basically undermine him around every
single turn uh leak all his stories so I
think genuinely this time around believe
it or not I think it'll be a better
Trump Administration than the first time
just cuz he knows the swamp better than
ever I I couldn't agree more and uh just
watching it one of the main things he
said was uh peace to strength I know
said it before but he's like this has
been just a lot of chaos I know you said
Pat this year is going to be the year of
chaos I actually have something to say
about that later but he also says he
knew he knows who his VP is he obviously
didn't want to say he did say he knows
his VP already he goes I know 100% he
said Chris Christie right yeah and I
thought that was the funniest part that
was the number one viewed clip on Fox
news by the way hilarious hilarious and
then um they asked him Brett Bar was
like well both of them were like can you
tell and he's like well maybe if you had
me on another show so I mean he's being
funny but he said uh when he gets in
it's going to be he's going to lead the
largest deportation effort in the
history of the country and guess what
that's going to be a lot of work because
he also said that by the time this four
years is done the numbers that we're
seeing Patrick are completely off he
said by the time Biden is done guys are
you ready for this 18
million 18 million illegals are going to
be into in this country and as we know
that they could apparently vote uh he
also said he doesn't have time for
Retribution I that's one of the best
things that he said is he doesn't have
time for this I'm going to get you I'm
going to get you we are failing the ship
is sinking he's going to have to come in
and save it I just hope to God that they
let him do it because the year of chaos
who knows what's coming down the pipe
that's right he said ret he said the
greatest retribution is massive success
that's how he put it which is you know
the famous quote the greatest revenge of
all time and I by the way I kind of like
when he said that the fact that look
we're going to win so much that's our
retribution to all the haters out there
Tom yeah I I think what you're seeing
here is a highly focused Donald Trump as
a result of all these assaults on him
these assaults take a toll on any man no
matter how strong you are and what I
think I'm seeing here is a focused
genuine Trump that looks presidential
but what and I'm saying to myself why do
I think he's looking better why do I
think he's looking like a leader because
I think he's focused I think he's got
underlying purpose and I think he
understands that they'll stop and
nothing trying to do it so I think what
you saw there was basically
congratulations guys you've armed the
missile and it is it is now you know
it's on the Launchpad and he's got a lot
of focus and he's gaining momentum he's
less bombastic and more and more
measured in what he says but he hasn't
gone Pat McAfee on this Pat he's not
listening to a bunch of advisers and
gone Pat McAfee at all what he's done
you are seeing measured versus bombastic
you are seeing leadership preparing you
are seeing realization of of how the
enemy goes after him and I think you put
all that together last night and I
believe there are democratic strategists
out there such as a prior president of
these United States that sees this and
they not going to say it publicly but it
scares the hell out of them which is why
after Obama was trying to coach Biden
Biden's team wasn't reacting to it that
Obama's been leaking all these things
and by the way ladies and gentlemen
Obama's leaking this he's leaking all
these conversations with Biden because
he's trying to get him and his team to
to do it that way cuz he came behind
closed doors and tried to talk to him
and they they said no no no we're going
to keep the strategy group over here
we're going to keep these things 100
miles
apart and guess what I think they're
scared to death of what they saw on that
stage last night and Tom I think you you
uh brought up the right word that I
think would be very useful for him and
that word is measured I remember
listening to a presidential historian
where they did what is it called when
you do layout like a word map you've
done that when we what's that called
like a word uh it's a word map yeah word
map sure some of the words are bigger
yeah some of the words and they said
like what's the most important quality
for a president this is the um
presidential hisory he said measured
you're dealing with so much stuff you
got so much going on and it's
essentially what you talk about in
junior asames wisely it's stoicism when
you use emotions stoic emotion doesn't
mean you're not emotional it just
doesn't mean you get triggered or you're
thin skinned we all know that Trump if
he's hit you know someone hits him he
hits back 10 times harder don't forget
the backdrop of this whether you think
think he cared or not his wife's mother
just died they're the exact same age she
just died he's a somber he's posted on
his
Instagram he's been married to Melania
for what 20 years now like it ain't just
a stunt ain't a PR thing we actually
took a bet whether they would stay
together after Presidency ended in 2020
they're still together his mom dies he's
on a debate stage he looked measured he
looked cool he looked calm he looked
collected how many times can you say
that about Trump those words in one
sentence so I think you there there's
the picture right there she looks like a
older M it's crazy funny but I think he
and then and then Nuance I think it gave
a very nuanced appropriate response to
the culture
wars in this country certainly ring
abortion he understands that that is a
major major topic that women listen a
100,000 votes one way or another will
determine this election whether it's in
Detroit Detroit whether it's in Madison
whether it's in Philly whether it's in
Vegas wherever it is 100,000 votes will
move and if you can convince 10,000
20,000 30,000 women to say you know what
I actually like that response on
abortion he said it's such a polarizing
issue if we can kind of come together as
he called out to santis a little bit on
this he basically said it wouldn't be
without R versus Wade being under
overturned with the Supreme Court
because of me the judges that I picked
63 basically Monopoly right now we
wouldn't even be having this
conversation he said that to
was supp the s that her main issue was
on abortion that's right correct so to
me it comes down to policy and it comes
down to personality his personality
seems a lot more cool and measured
Donald our friend utilize that people
appreciate when you don't have to be a
you know Don Rickles comedian up there
but then also policy-wise I think you
give a very nuanced approach to the
Border I mean very strength and then
abortion so I think he did a great job
last night I would give him an A and I
think um just to add to that in less
than 10 seconds over the last 3 months
we're seeing voting blocks trickle back
to Trump and we're seeing him gain
little tiny bits of voting blocks that
you didn't expect to be coming back and
that's happening in the back drop and
that also scares the hell but but let's
but don't forget guys we're a year out
the Trump that we all know and a lot of
people out there love is going to come
because the shots are going to start
being fired and guess what he's going to
fire back and don't get it twisted when
this is all nice and he's being
presidential and when he gets in guess
what not retribution he is not going to
f around cuz now he's jumping right back
into that same swamp and now his eyes
are going to be open because like and I
get into these arguments all the time
well video Christopher Ray he he
appointed Christopher Ray why I go I go
bro he doesn't know anybody in that
whole realm when somebody like bar or
somebody goes hey I recommend pom uh
Pompeo Mike Pompeo you know what you
should get this guy he has to hire
people he's not in Washington and he
learned his lesson and now I think this
next this next year is you're going to
see the gloves start coming off as we
get later I think that question goes
into the next one right and that is the
debate that happened last night between
the santis and Haley yeah which I got a
I got a lot of thoughts on that debate
last night and and Rob I don't know if
you have any of the videos or not uh it
was not pretty right off the bat you
could tell these two don't like each
other it was calling out character it
was from from the and by the way even if
you open up the open if you type in uh
find the Santa's opening okay just
purely his opening he dropped bomb after
bomb after bomb on Haley it wasn't even
like let's wait 19 minutes to get into
it let's wait 7 minutes to get into it
nothing boom he hit her and not once it
was like a boxer just coming like with
them and yeah like holy and then
she realized because I think the reason
why he did that and and Rob if you have
the opening I wouldn't mind playing it
is that the opening it is I'm getting oh
dude I loved his opening if if we can
get it I'd love to play the clip of the
opening I know it's see if you can do
that right there go all the way to the
top see if it's not refreshing just well
that's kind of like when uh the came out
with his opening red hot in Miami at the
debate Ronald McDaniel and calling it
was fantastic but when you see it you're
going to think about why would he come
out so strong right after he says that
guess what Nikki Haley drops what she
says go to the STIs lies.com go to the
Santas lies.com she probably said the
Santas lies.com 30 times did you see the
traffic the website got seven people
signed up for that uh website now it's
big time up the S it was
nonstop traffic nonstop of her promoting
this website uh but I think he got a win
that she was going to come hard and
calling out his character for the the
trust and the lies and I think she was
going to go hardcore after them I want
to see this clip but do me a favor go to
Twitter a poll I ran last night right
after the debate go to a poll I ran last
night right after the debate this the
poll I ran okay uh uh uh just vote on
one of them whatever just okay so watch
this who do you trust more look at that
26,000 people voted okay look at Haley
1.8% that not below the margin I put
neither because some people are going to
be like well you know be and Trump and
you know RFK and all a choice but but 30
to one do people do not trust Haley but
Haley's got the big dollars that she's
getting she was able to get the big
dollars and they walked away from the
santis he called her called them out on
it on the $150 million that you've spent
and he's just upset that he lost the
money and they came to you and uh I
don't know I I watched the whole thing
and I said the santis is 10 times more
presidential than Haley is it ain't even
close to me my eyes I fully agree with
you I think if I have given the choice
with these two options let's just be
clear this is the JV option right there
this is not the heavyweight fight this
is the lightweight bout but these two
lightweights went on stage and I would
vote for DeSantis 100 times out of 100
over Nikki Haley no question but this
was a uh pummeling of uh two Poli iCal
lightweights this was a sloppy food
fight in the political Arena but instead
of tossing mashed potatoes and gravy and
green pens they toss lies name calling
and call outs and it was ugly and it
just goes to show I kind of understand
why Trump basically was like yeah I'm
good on these debates I'm above The Fray
here I'll do my measured Town Halls I'll
do my my thing with Tucker like you
remember the first debate without
jumping on the stage with this now
christe's out VC our boy he should have
been on on stage where was he you got
Nikki and you got Ron just calling each
other out the best line that I think
that Nikki had against the santis was
the mismanagement of $150 million she
said you were given $150 million and you
mismanage the hell out of it ran
basically how the hell are you going to
handle a$ 26 trillion GDP or $34
trillion deficit that we got going on
debt in America they're both quick they
both know their stuff they both came
prepared but there just need there seems
to be a credibility issue with Nikki
there's a video of her Nikki saying
recently where she's on stage and she's
talking about how much she Hillary
Clinton was one of the people did you
just say killary Clinton inspiration did
I say kill I don't I don't know why that
might Hillary it might have been a
Freudian slip but she's using if you use
Hillary Hillary Clinton as inspiration
this is what you get that attitude that
bitterness and no wonder why Trump got
rid of I saw two things happen last
night for me when I looked at this first
of all you know when I sawat poll coming
in it said to me you know what the voter
the people that are out there and we're
talking about the people that follow Pat
so don't tell me oh it's not a broad
poll no that's enough of a poll to tell
you the feelings are out there vivec's
been talking about it and he was the one
at to Dick Cheney and heels she's an
establishment candidate that was not
mudslinging that has turned out to be
100% true she's uncloaked and exposed to
everybody and the voters are saying I
don't want the establishment and I don't
want for Wars and I don't want this and
the voters are saying I don't want you
but what Pat just said yeah the
billionaires are getting behind her who
establishment billionaires that want the
establishment to continue status quo to
continue so the first thing that
happened to me is it was thank God I
think some of the voters are paying
attention to this at least by Pat's poll
but who the hell is polling in New
Hampshire and Iowa where she's getting
traction maybe people are realizing it
the other thing I saw on a less crowded
stage you saw d santis as the
knowledgeable argu you know good
structured argued policy wonk I agree it
was a food fight and it was sloppy and
messy but there is a one moment there it
was on the immigration
where DeSantis absolutely took down
Nikki Haley this is what you did in
South Carolina this is what you did with
China and the relationships this is what
you did here here and it wasn't these
you know election year spin claims it
was hard facts and I said you know what
that's the governor of Florida that a
lot of people in Florida including me
voted for and likeed the guy because
he's such a good policy guy and he's
such a driven guy but he's not
presidential but he looked more
presidential than she did but it was a
food fight but there is a glimpse in
there of the guy that the people of
Florida have seen and that's why we
elected him last point you know when
when you actually want to look at the
actual agenda there has to be a pathway
to the presidency we all know this so
the the first three states we know
Iowa's next next week dude like let the
games begin Iowa's next week by the way
it's like the coldest it's ever been in
Iowa this week the weather's been
ridiculous good call pbd not going to
Iowa I don't know I think something
better here in South Florida but the
three states that are coming up are Iowa
New Hampshire and South Carolina if
Ronda Santos does not come in first or
second in Iowa he's finished because
he's not pulling well in New Hampshire
Nikki's pulling well in New Hampshire
Chris Christie just jumped out of the
race a lot of his 12% that he's winning
in New Hampshire might come to her she
might give Trump a run for a money New
Hampshire we'll see but then the third
state is South Carolina that's Nikki's
home state she was the governor of South
Carolina so her pathway looks a lot
better if the santis fumbles in Iowa no
Rob none of these videos are working you
know why because from my end they're all
working here I don't I have a message in
or Tech Team to find out why do you know
did you are you able to show the other
one I sent you or none of them are shown
those two are not working for some
reason everything else is though really
those two are not working so there's one
of the clips well if you can't play it
there what I'll do is I'll play it here
just just for you to hear please the
audio and what he says because what what
what he says about her you talking about
Chris
Christie the hot mic will pull up here
in a second no guys well one of them is
the opening but it it's it's when he
makes the comparison of ah man you have
to listen to the listen guys just forget
about it the words is what matters I
mean you already know what Ron's look
like here why should voters who are
looking for an alternative to the
current front runner former president
Trump vote for you rather than former
Governor Haley well the people of Iowa
good evening it's great to be and Iowa
to have a debate here Donald Trump's
running to pursue his issues Nikki
Haley's running to pursue her donor's
issues I'm running to pursue your issues
and your family's issues and to turn
this country around I'm the only one
running that's delivered on 100% of the
promises that I've made we've delivered
huge victories in the State of Florida
things that Republicans have been asking
for for a generation I'm also the only
one running that has beaten the left
time and time again we beat the teachers
union on universal school choice we beat
Soros on crime we beat fouchy on covid
we beat the Dems on Election integrity
and I beat the left by Banning China
from buying land in the State of Florida
now uh you know Nikki Haley is is
running uh we don't need another mey
mouth politician who just tells you what
think you want to hear just to try to
get your vote then to get in office and
to do her donor's bidding she was in
another state and she said the people of
Iowa's votes need to be corrected this
is somebody that wrote in her book that
Hillary Clinton inspired her to first
run for office I remember Hillary
denigrating people on the Republican
side as deplorables we don't need a
candidate who's going to look down on
Middle America uh we've had enough of
that I'm the only one that's going to be
able to lead this country's Revival uh
I'm asking for your support and I won't
let you down wow Governor by the way I
loved it I loved and then and then
there's a there's a part where they have
a back and forth where he says about
Nome okay this one is actually very
funny I'm sure some of you guys heard
this watch this Nikki Haley and me you
know I listened to all that Litany of
stuff you know I debated the governor of
California Gavin Nome um you know I
thought he lied a lot man Nikki Haley
May gives him a run for his money and
may even be more liberal than is I think
the difference between that that's
pretty solid by the way so you know
Donald Trump is campaigning for his
issues Nikki Haley is campaigning for
her donor's issues I'm campaigning for
your issues whoever wrote that that
writer wherever you are highi good for
you he's been saying that line wherever
he goes whatever it is I love it I love
the fact that he said that by the way a
few different things when it comes out
to education she was talking about
education oh let me tell you I'm this
with your
education her State as a governor she's
ranked 42 out of 50 when it comes down
to education um there was other
discussions about where he called her
out when she like well what are you
talking about with Ukraine you keep
talking about Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine
you want us to do more money for Ukraine
and then she gives her argument and
spinning at the fact that hey you're
making Putin stronger and then the STIs
says even on Megan Kelly when he P when
she pushed you on why would you want
Ukraine because she said she wants a
solution of Ukraine being part of NATO
he says why would you do that and I'm
making Kelly pushed if Ukraine is part
of NATO isn't that directly putting us
at war with Russia she fumbled through
the answer couldn't give it I thought I
was very
effective uh he says leadership is about
getting things done stop making excuses
then she turns from getting things done
and she says he's just upset because his
donors came to me and he says what
difference does it matter if the donors
came to me you know the money it doesn't
mean anything with issues it just means
they came to you right still she didn't
answer the question that he brought up
um uh she says that's she said
specifically Trump lost the election
Biden won the election January 6 is one
of the worst days in the history of
America the these are things that she's
talking about she's not talking about
the fact that there was any metaling or
you know Twitter New York Post story
nothing that's cheating but she didn't
put that got you know the santis called
or what she said about George Floyd
where she said George Floyd you know
this is a one of the worst days and you
know giv all that stuff that she talked
about you know kind of falling for the
black lives matter uh division that was
taking place um you know at the end when
they asked the question they said so
what do you say about Haley says well I
like that she did this and she did that
and she did this hey Governor Haley what
do you like about Governor DeSantis he's
a good Governor that's it that's it
there's no and the hosts were
uncomfortable there's like a 5-second
pause did you do you remember that Rob
can you find that when she says he's a
good governor or Haley he's a good is
that the one right there I think that's
it watch this year if you can play
it Governor Dan santis let me ask you
what do you admire about Governor Haley
well look I mean I think that um you
know at the United Nations um I did
think that she she spoke out strongly on
some key issues and I appreciated that I
also appreciate uh the state of South
Carolina my wife uh is a College of
Charleston graduate um her parents live
there for many many years and so it is a
wonderful State uh there's a lot of
great people there um and I think to be
able to have been Governor there is is a
great achievement and um I uh really
appreciate everyone I've gotten to meet
in South Carolina governor Haley what do
you admire about Governor DeSantis I
think he's been a good
Governor dude she look at those dark she
looks like a Wicked Witch of the West
she looks she looks like let me tell you
something this is probably going to be
set off the RoR scale this is the the
problem
with having females in power and
Leadership I'm just saying what are you
saying they get super emotional
obviously they hate each other yeah but
he still has the ability to say you know
what I like South Carolina and and like
kind of put lipstick on a pig she's like
she's a mean girl she's a freaking Mean
Girl by the way Mean Girls is coming out
this weekend she's a mean girl she gets
emotional is she smart is she capable if
she tough sure does she Dick cheny and
heels great right she use her heels as a
machine gun whatever the hell the
reference was yeah but at the at the
time where you could just be
nice for two seconds he's the G gaver
you're lying even Hillary could do
it Hillary I was just going to say she's
worse than Hillary she's worse but but
do you see that like dude just look at
her aura look at her Persona and you
know what it comes down to when you
spent 68 or what almost 70 million on
your campaign because you're a war
machine you're a war hawk and guess what
it's starting to look like the guy
that's going to come in doesn't want war
and we're not going to try to go to war
that's the face that you make and that's
evil cuz she wants people to die bro you
want war you want people to die and
that's that angry I'm not going to get
the war that all these people are are
are investing in something nasty I agree
with that point 100% she's a nasty woman
she's nasty no about the the whole War
Machine stuff something else happens
when fewer and fewer and fewer people
are on stage for these debates and
they're not debates they're sound bites
and responses this isn't real like
structured debate but when the crowd on
stage is
smaller the light shines brighter and
the truth comes out because you can't
stand over here do you remember when
DeSantis was just smiling in the middle
while awkwardly smiling awkwardly while
the St Louis Arch was going over him in
this this war between Vic and Haley
remember that with with Christy over
there chiming in from the other side
supporting uh Haley in her assault on VC
you can't do that when there's only two
people on stage you don't get you you
don't get hey I'm going to take this
round off and I'm just going to sit here
and smile and I'm going to let these two
people run their character
assassinations or drop their sound bites
on each other that they attack all of
the sudden the truth of who you are come
out and you look at her expression you
look at was there you see the
establishment War
Machine personified and you see a
measured policy wonk that I don't think
is ready to be president on the other
side and bit of a food fight I love the
fact you called it a food fight I think
such unappropriate this is what said by
the way this is what Vic is predicting
which by the way I I let me know if you
agree with this or not with can
processes but go ahead the system wants
to narrow this down to a two-horse race
between Donald Trump and a puppet who
they can control and it has become
increasingly clear that puppet is not a
Democrat it's not even Gavin Newsome
it's Nikki Haley it's in our own party
well today one more step in that plot
unfolds Chris Christie drops out next up
I'm going to make a prediction you're
actually going to see Ronda santis join
Nikki Hilly's ticket he's going to be
her VP the whole game it's hiding in
plain sight whatever it takes and this
system will stop at nothing and I mean
nothing to eliminate Donald Trump from
contention it's disgusting but the same
people who have said they're not going
to actually take a principled stand
against Trump's removal from the ballot
Haley and Dan santis are both in that
category do the math people that's next
up Ron Des santis is after Iowa
everybody including Chris Christie
apparently got a phone call from Ronda
santis panicked was the word that Chris
Christie used this is the way the plots
going Ron may not know this Ronda sanis
may not know this but that's what his
donors are going to make him do that's
what's coming next Ronda Sanz will
become Nikki's VP whether or not Ron
knows it it's not really his choice he's
not the one in charge of that decision
and then the plot continues we have to
open our eyes and not fall into their
trap our America First agenda cannot end
our movement cannot end with Donald
Trump when they take him out from
contention and if you think this system
is going to even let this man get
anywhere near the White House we need to
open our eyes we need to do the right
thing for our country they are selling
us the Rope today that they're going to
use to hang us tomorrow do not fall into
the Trap people and that's why I'm here
can I say one thing about this guy yeah
when it comes to being a communicator 10
out of 10 Vic ramaswami I would say that
he's the Andrew Tate of politics today I
mean gifted
Beyond teaching communicator and when it
comes down to Trump being the nominee
which I think we we know it's inevitable
other than VP Vic take your pick
whatever cabinet position you want you
got it that's how good he is and he's
only 38 years old I I mean I was just
going to ask you if right now you had to
guess no guys guys guys guys guys
isolate what he just said do you agree
with him the fact that the santis is
going to drop out and be Nikki Haley's
VP do you agree with with that
assessment Tom I don't I don't think I
line up with that
assessment but I 100% line up with his
core thought that there are bigger
wheels and bigger hands moving levers in
the in the election well I think
everybody knows that right Tom to your
point but everybody knows that there's
something going on behind the scenes
it's not like whoa breaking news the
Deep State doesn't want Trump in there
we know that but his his manner of which
it happens the mechanisms the teaming up
with the lady he just got in a food
fight with I'm sorry Des Santa teaming
up with Haley I don't see that happening
but VC knows some it seem some
that we've never even known uh like
behind closed doors yeah but but but
that's not so farfetched I mean look at
what kamla kamla crapped all over Joe
Biden like you racist and you and then
the next day she's like oh he's the
greatest it's politics and they're all
full of I I mean it's a possibility
I don't think so her famous attack on
kamla Harris when he said and I don't
know of a of a really successful woman
who's you know been all the way to to
the to the Senate and she goes I'm right
here you know remember she was yelling
right next him I'm right here and you're
right and then later it was you know so
what do you think Tom let's go back to
this do you think this is going to
happen or no do you think the santis is
going to drop out and go endorse Haley I
believe santis is going to drop out I do
not I I believe that his his donors went
to her and that's a sign for me I think
he'll support her will he be on her
ticket I don't think so I don't think
she's gonna have a so you exact if so
Christy comes out and by the way do you
have the recording for Christy Rob if
you can just play that recording Christy
comes out and you know go ahead go ahead
and play
that and don't forget she spent $68
million yeah I mean we spent like well
when you give land to China and places
like that yeah that's what you get yeah
yeah I mean look she spent 68 million so
far just on TV spent 68 million so far
59 million by D santis and we spent 12 I
mean who's punching above their weight
and who's getting a return on their
investment you know and she's going to
get smoked and you and I both know it
she's not up to this she hasn't even
she's still 20 points behind Trump in
New Hampshire right yeah oh yeah and
he's going to he's still going to carry
a right yes oh he's I I talked to the
santis called me petrified he's probably
getting out half to Iowa
well
why does Chris chrisy continue to make
weight jokes I mean how does how is he
he's punching above her weight Trump is
unfit to be president yeah Christy
respect bro have you looked in a mirror
recently what's with the weight jokes
Pat I believe there's a lot goes on with
the donors and if the donors have left
the donuts Chris Christie the donut
donor donors so the donors that have
left D santis and gone to Haley those
donors many of them aren't just his
presidential donors they were his
gubernatorial donors and so I think the
donors carry a lot of weight and so will
Dan santis begrudgingly support Haley
when he drops out I think he will and I
think there's a donor mechanism back
there but will he pledge to be her VP
I'm a hard no Pat to stay on topic just
think about in the last 6 months to 12
months what do Sanz could have done he
could have been freaking Trump's VP I if
he had loyalty now we're basically
saying he's going to be basically Niki
Haley's potential VP think about the
exact opposite of transcendence that
Ronda Sanz has done what do you think
what do you think I've been saying this
since May I mean I've been saying this
since his book came out April May oh
yeah no I know that oh you know where I
stand with that position but some people
when Des Sanz is by himself by himself I
I think he's a good guy I think Des
Santa is a good guy okay I don't like
Haley and I don't trust Haley I just
like let me rephrase like I don't know
her so I can't say I don't like her or
not I don't like her approach she comes
across like I told you already you know
I'm better than you and I'm you know
telling the waitress hey hey come here I
I see her as that that she's above
everybody right I'm not a fan of that
but to me the santis is probably by
himself you know sitting there when you
lose a championship what do you do
you're like man what if I made that play
and I would have screened and I would
have done this and I didn't hustle for
the ball and why didn't I hustle for the
ball what was I thinking when I fou the
guy I knew I had already four fouls and
I was going to be taking on the fourth
quarter with seven minutes of what are
you what are you thinking what a stupid
foul am I you're going through all
you're replaying all this stuff you as
an athlete you know exactly what I'm
talking about you do this in
relationship you do this in friendships
you do this in business you do this in
sports he's going to go through that and
he's already doing that and and you
rarely do that with others you only do
that with yourself you don't even do
that with your wife sometimes you do it
with yourself he's done that already but
at the same time guess what this is the
game of politics man I was having a
conversation with a couple of my guys
early on in my career one time I had the
most embarrassing loss ever it was so
bad that the chairman of the company in
front of a thousand people brought me up
on stage it was me and this other guy
and they were going to give the MVP in
the history of the company this has
never happened before where they bring
the loser and the winner on stage and
they make the loser give the winner the
MVP and they're trying to dig and they
know this works with me so it's good so
I'm like okay so I go up there and like
who do you think and who do you think
and who do you think and obviously he
ends up winning the MVP and I I hand the
MVP over to the guy and I whispered to
him I said respect to you you outworked
me this year you get the credit for this
I said but let's face it bro you and I
are not the same level for the rest of
your life people going to forget about
you they're not going to forget about
what I'm going to do wow went on stage
gave him the respect I edified him I
gave him love
I salute him I said I love the fact that
we're doing this came back gave a
message to our team guys you guys have
been fantastic you've done your part but
let me tell you no one has any clue
what's going to happen when we go back
went back to the group we had a nice
little meeting with them and then we
came back and killed everybody you have
to learn how to lose it sucks learning
how to lose sucks it sucks and by the
way for people are like well you know
you don't know what you're talking about
because Michael had to learn how to lose
with the Detroit Pistons and he came
back and he redeemed himself the
greatest athlete of all time had to
learn how to lose so he has to go
through this process of knowing how to
do that and come out and still
say what loyalty do I have to Nikki
Haley nothing what loyalty do I have to
Trump more than
Haley say you hate them both this guy's
done more for me than she's done for me
she's a backstabbing manipulating do I
really want to go behind this person
because if she if he does endorse Haley
he not only loses a job in the
administration say if he wants it but
forget about the administration you lose
a shot in the future because if he does
come out and go this way guess what
Trump's going to do Trump's going to
forgive like this move on and come back
and edify and build him up right so I
think the santz is going through that
right now and I I I I don't know whether
he's going to go and Endor I don't know
if I agree with Vic uh I think the right
move is step out don't endorse anybody
yet just keep it cool keep it collected
let them call you have a private meeting
with everybody have a private meeting
with Trump's Camp you know you your
Camp's going to talk to his camp and see
what you guys can work out together and
then if you are afraid of what's going
to happen with America and what
direction we're going then what would it
look like if you and Trump are seen on
stage together wow and you guys say
stuff to each other you know he's going
to build you up you know you're going to
build him up you know what you're going
to do to America you're going to do to
America what Nikki Haley can't do okay
that's what you're going to do Nikki
Haley's establishment you're hybrid some
people think you're establishment some
people think you're not anti you're
anti-establishment I think you're more
Trump than you are Haley I I think
that's what's going to happen and I'd
like to see that take place but it is
politics this is an unpredictable game
and Tom makes a point with the donors so
you going to have to know the donors
have a lot of control we'll see what's
going to happen there in uh that's my
position on this situation here anyways
let's move forward to the next story
here all right so let's go
to uh uh which one do we want to go to
let's go to SEC authorizes Bitcoin spot
ETF in cryptos breakthrough there's uh
uh this is uh uh R is this the most
recent recent story because one just
came out last night do you have the most
recent one is that the one I'm reading
because that's the one I want to read
let no the most recent one will be up on
the screen okay then pull up the one up
on the screen so SEC approves rule
change that paved the way for Bitcoin
ETF the approval could prove uh to be a
landmark event in the adoption of
cryptocurrency by mainstream Finance the
decision will likely lead to the
conversion of grayscale Bitcoin trust
which holds $29 billion of
cryptocurrency into an nftd traditional
asset managers include Black Rock and
Fidelity are also poised to launch
Bitcoin funds this has two different
meanings Tom said something before we
start the podcast I don't want to steal
a thunder I want him to give his
perspective on what he thinks this is to
him because a lot of people are sitting
there saying this is big this is this
this is that Tom what does this mean to
you um congratulations Bitcoin this is
day one of your regulated life uh that
is what's happening here it doesn't mean
that all the good things and everything
about crypto and Bitcoin are going away
it just means that there is people
saying this legitimizes Bitcoin well I
would challenge that statement and say
you're you're right but this also steps
up where you're going to regulate
Bitcoin and what's interesting is SEC
chair Gary Gensler he clarified he said
let me clarify this quote while we
approve the listing and trading of spot
Bitcoin ETP shares we did not approve or
endorse Bitcoin wait a minute you did
approve it it's basically like the pimp
saying I'm happy to make money on
prostitution but I don't endorse it
that's exactly what pimps up hes down
Tom go for it big pimp what he just said
B they're they are desperately trying
not to endorse it but they are they are
also eagerly stepping forward to start
regulating it so basically what they've
said is now it can be trade so in other
words an ETF can buy some Bitcoin and
put it in there that's what they're
saying so if you bought an ETF that was
in you know spec cative currencies or
something like that and it's got a few
things in there okay now Bitcoin can be
part of that basket but this is this is
day one of a different future for
Bitcoin it does legitimize it but it
also means that now the sec's can be
making the rules so I think they're
calling this a watershed moment for
Bitcoin look we see that Bitcoin is now
at 475 I think it's alltime Peak was
what in the high 60s almost 70 so
they're saying that this could be the
reason that it can Pummel it up to
$100,000 coin we'll see what happens
there but look re regulation for the
most part can be a good thing what does
regulation do you guys know this dealing
with the insurance stuff and the annuity
stuff and the financial planning stuff
you said legitimacy no doubt it gives
trust into the marketplace and it gives
credibility So Bad actors and people who
are basically taking advantage of people
sorry you're not going to be able to
scam as many people with whatever you're
doing there's going to be some
regulation there and overregulation as I
think what people have a problem with
but laying down regulation the the law
of the land so to speak the the the the
road map to how to basically trade this
type of asset class I think overall is
going to be a good thing and I think
it'll help legitimize the good actors in
The crypto space and by the way a lot of
there's a community in the crypto side
that wants that there's a community in
the crypto sounds like dude just tell us
what the regulation is so we can you
know we can pay it accordingly and move
forward yeah I look at regulation like
if you look at a football game you know
very nuanced game is a 50 the rul you
never heard of football all the guys out
there so there's American you know
there's American football guys and then
there's the regular fo what I'm saying
is tell us the rules like you know but
like in general it's like okay 10 yards
is a first down good got it right you
can kick a field goal on fourth down
like basic rules two point like Ru
rather than hey you 11 you 11 just run
around and do and we'll just kind
of keep scor the end no there's
regulation that now when they're like
over regulated it gets to the point
where it's a where well you can't dance
in the end zone or if you're not if your
socks aren't a certain length that's
overregulation but regulation in sport
and in finance is actually a good thing
without being too cumbersome and
burdensome on the rules in 2008 it was a
good thing that they came back and they
regulated you know loans cuz a lot of
basic American consumers got really hurt
by getting into bad loans Nina yeah they
came back no income no asset that's
right they came back and by the way the
people people pushing them into it
mortgage brokers wanted their commission
but then the the the clientele the
consumer often not an informed consumer
was taken advantage of and ended up in
debt and a bad pinch with that so it
some regulation is good it's good that
insurance companies are regulated so
there's a a sufficient loss Reserve so
that you know if everybody covered by
State Farm Home Insurance in Alabama
when a hurricane comes through State
Farm has the money to pay and it's good
to have that regulation there where the
overregulation happens is what's
happening now in insurance is where
Elizabeth Warren says wait a minute I
don't think the salesp people should
make this kind of a commission wait wait
who the hell are you the do stuff she's
doing yeah yeah yeah who the hell are
you you know we have a good industry
here people are getting an insurance
policy it's protecting their family the
money is there when when the you know
ultimate the person passes away so it
can protect the family in s of serve the
family and you're here on the front end
trying to tell people what they should
pay their employees and turn a
commission yeah baby you take you and
your fake you know Native American
background and get out of this get out
of this side of it that's overregulation
to your point you leave pahas alone okay
is that the most expensive thing for
like cuz for one Bitcoin
$47,000 is that the most expensive thing
for one thing on the for for stock
market what do you mean no no no Burk
halfway is like you know birkar halfway
it it's always hovering between $250 to
$500,000 if you want to BU one type in
what is burar halfway
share for one share one share what is
bur halfway share a and b$ 553,000 for
one share right now one share this is
the cloud this is the a burshire a if
you have one share of Burkshire go to go
to fiveyear uh go to a five-year on
where you are go all the way to the
right yeah there you go oh so it's look
at it it's a it's $553,000 a share right
now for Brookshire hathway they do okay
if you wanted to buy a share Pat just
Tau me something see no I didn't know
that Burkshire 500 so you own an a if
you own a certain amount of aare or an
aare you get to go to their annual
shareholder meeting great which is held
in Omaha and you hear him go back and
forth which will no longer happen with
the late Charlie Monger but yeah so
that's that part next next question
California lawmakers to consider ban on
tackle football for kids under the age
of 12 is this a good thing or is this a
bad thing so California lawmakers are
set to discuss a bill proposing ban on
this for children under 12 with the
first public hearing underway the bill
authored by Democratic assembly member
Kevin mccardy
McCarthy different than one you think
aims to protect children from documented
brain damage risk associated with tackle
football proposed amendments would
gradually phase into ban until 2029 if
it passes Advocates argue that tackle
football possesses a significant risk of
brain damage including chronic traumatic
uh enal La apathy or something like that
CTE and assert that children should not
be exposed to these dangers while no
State has yet banned youth tackle
football similar bills introduced in
California New York and Illinois
previously failed to pass despite a
decline in high school tackle football
participation in California wow a
participation in California there was a
5% increase in 2023 reaching 89,1 78
Vinnie good idea or bad idea first of
all I I I think it's look at that
participation dropped in tackle football
from 15 to 22 by 18% from 103,000 kid
stomp to 84,000 but last year it went
from 84,000 to 89,000 go ahead it's
funny how California cares about kids
getting tackled at 12 years old but
guess what gender chop your crotch off
they're they're totally cool like we'll
we'll protect your brain but when it
comes to your crotch and your genitalia
guess what get rid of it like look look
at the priorities of California it all
comes down the Gavin Nome what a what a
hor like who gives a like that's your
concern but when it comes to their
sexuality and everything chop it off I
think it I think it's stupid I think at
that age as we all know P because you
played Adam played Tom you were doing
something uh
tackling tackling at 12 that's that's
when you're supposed to be getting
tackled and if God forbid something
happens you break a bone it heals like
that that's what gets you tougher that's
what get that gets these boys to be uh
participating I I think it's stupid has
an opposing position to him Tom are you
different than where he's at I look at
it this way California is trying to
protect children but they're doing it
yeah in this one narrow little way you
know Kevin McCarthy wants to protect
kids from tackle football there's a lot
of stats out there there was also some a
year ago I I after a year ago I think I
brought the stat to the podcast if you
take a look at families earning more
than $50,000 a year and families earning
less than $50,000 a year football
particip ation for those over $50,000 a
year was plummeting and you've got stats
that it's plummeting and Lacrosse and
soccer were skyrocketing those were
those were the replacements because kids
want to play they want to be competitive
whereas the under 50,000 people still
had their kids participating in football
it is a fact that the younger you start
the more you're exposed to CTE and the
NFL has had a lot of things going on
with CTE and had an unfortunate truth
there I I just don't think it's the
state to ultimately ban it this is
stepping in more where parents should
make decisions if you're going to ban
football completely ban it get that
through Congress see if you can do that
yeah good luck ban it good luck it's a
sport we play it it's National and you
can make a decision to do it or not now
let me go one one step further now do
you step in and say kids under 12 can't
ride skateboards and do tricks at the
skate parks and can't ride Motocross and
do all X game say because it's not safe
and because you get head injury where
does it stop I think it's wrong for
California to get involved and to do
this this is parents' decision if I want
to let my kid do X Games uh skateboard
stunts and I'm going to risk the
injuries to him if I'm going to let him
Adam do Motocross that's up to me as a
parent so I played football in high
school I played football in college let
me tell you something at the end of the
day boys are going to play football dude
yep tackling each other like some of my
greatest memories and talking about 12
years old middle school any of my
friends that are watching the show
remember every Friday all the boys there
was 20 of us whatever it was we'd go to
the the field right behind the school
pick teams dude just destroy each other
12 years old 13 years old we did that
every single year every single Friday
had the best time of our lives to this
day we still talking bro remember when
you crack back your boy that's what boys
are going to do but when it gets to
actual tack so cool want to play flag
football I get it if you're young play
flag football but what football's going
to do and playing with pads is a totally
different sport than playing flag okay I
know kids that were 12 13 14 fast tough
kids you put some pads on no
they're out forget about that that's why
they say the Jewish guys Peak when
they're basically 13 I don't know I
outgrew my I outgrew my uh 6' 200 lb but
what football will do like no other
sport it'll teach you teamwork
leadership accountability commitment
toughness grit out aggression we
know about testosterone in this country
resilience masculinity this is good for
young boys and I don't know how you're
going to regulate someone trying to go
out back play the football throw around
the pig skin get tough have fun you make
friends you make enemies you learn about
life all on the football field don't
overregulation football is basically
let's take their land right and so you
get together you make a plan you go up
there with blitzes and bombs and other
things and you're basically trying to
and if you're dude and it's welcoming if
you're in the lgbtq AI plus Community
everybody's wearing tights if you're the
quarterback you can put your hand under
a guy's crotch and just yell numbers red
38 you could just no it's welcoming it's
loving it's you get to shower with
everybody there's great positions like
tight end wide receiver receiver the
pulling guard something football is
grooming that's what I'm say that's what
I'm saying guys so it's wel oh my gosh
but it's uh yeah I think dude I think
California has has more important
to worry about than 12-year-old kids
wearing their helmets they're they're
protecting their brains bro how about
protecting their gender and not letting
them uh chop off the genit andless their
parents decide what your mom I think
it's a parents when it comes to the
sports thing I don't think like Nikki
Haley said going back Nikki haly where
they asked her about gender affirming
care for a 12-year-old you know what she
said that's that's up to the parents no
no no no no because you could be a
psychotic parent and go you know what I
want my kid to to be a girl now he was
born a boy because he told me once that
that's what he wants no no no I don't
play that you know what me and
Vinnie do when time to time we're just
you know in between podcasts we
literally go outside in the freaking
parking lot literally throw the rout I
throw routes I do routes on concrete
we're throwing routes Vinnie's Ling out
he's tip tone in the end zone I I dented
Natalia's car I hit my head on but you
caught the ball resilience toughness
this is what we're talking about now
Matthew's the mouthpiece we got to work
on his own B weol this was very
insightful Vinnie the angle you took I
never thought about how welcoming the
sport of football really is level of
brilliant that's what you call wisdom
though that's the wisdom of a 45-year
old man appreciate that served in the
Air Force Air of the
can I can I say one thing too I'm get
I've been getting man on here like just
shout out to everybody just really fast
P Joe Robert Eduardo Marco they're all
like hey you're getting that
suit I love you guys trying to help you
get I love Daddy need a new suit yeah
all right let's go to the let's go to
the next one by the way you see the QR
code for some of you guys that haven't
yet maned yeah there I am just load
price again give him a shout out guys
it's free Tom's doing it for free at
this point he don't need the money let's
go let's go to the next one uh do we
want to go to the underground tunnel do
you want to go to the comments they made
about the assassination the journalist
or do you want to go to Eric Adams
migrant staying in homes in New York we
have we have to do the New York one
newor which all we'll all stay in New
York anyway let's let's do that so New
York City students forced to go remote
As city houses nearly 2,000 migrants
displaced by storm at their schools
insane yes true yes here we go so
students at Brooklyn High School were
removed to remote learning to
accommodate nearly 2,000 migrants
evacuated from a storm threatened tent
shelter at Floyd Bennett uh field
leading to local residents concerns one
resident remarked this is effed up
expressing worry about the Immigrant
migrants background and vetting in
another question the decision asking why
not send them somewhere where students
wouldn't be disrupted the city's move
prompted by concerns of a collapsing
tent shelter due due to heavy rain and
strong winds with gusts up to 70 mph
forecasted the decision face backlash
from locals and some question the
suitability of Floyd Bennett's field as
a tent complex with one councilman
stating it was Common Sense do you have
the clip Rob to show this is there is
there a video clip you have on this I
sent them one of of a mom Pat she's
outside the school they're busing all
these people in and she's screaming it's
like midnight her kids have to go to
school the next day but now it's
cancelled uh did I say Rob did I send it
to you it's the Mom it's the Mom stre
rob you said you have an Eric Adams
migrant staying in a home I do I have a
clip of Eric Adams where he says that if
the shelters are overrun uh people may
have to start welcoming migrants play
this play this it's my vision uh to take
the next step to this go to the faith
base locals and then move to uh private
residents there are residents who are
suffering right now economic challenges
go back Tom I understand what that means
but go back to the go back for three
seconds yeah play that again right there
locals and then move to uh private
residents uh there are residents who are
suffering right now because of economic
challenges they have spare rooms uh they
have locals and if we can find a way to
get over the 30-day Rule and other rules
that government has in in its place we
can take that $4.2 billion 4 three it
may be now that we potentially have to
spend and we can put it back in the
pockets of everyday New
Yorkers listen what a great wait do you
understand what that means yeah yeah
hold on yeah yeah wait hold on what a
great idea guys all these illegals you
know what if you have a daughter if you
have young women in your house bring in
a couple of random dudes from another
country to be at home with your and this
is this is a lady outside James Madison
High School in Brooklyn this is dude
it's fenced off like J January 6th and
look what they're doing they're busting
in look at look at this mom is the
volume how does it feel do you feel good
I hope you feel good I hope you all
sleep really well tonight look it's like
a fortress an agitated mother that's why
look at the buses cops look at that look
at
this at unbelievable my
kid okay pause that so so let's go
through let's go through a couple things
your time mhm what do you mean mayor
says residents number one so so you mean
to tell me I have to take on people to
stay at my
house and and take care of them why do I
have to do that so your bad policies I'm
the benefici of it you chose that bad
policy of sanctuary City you chose that
bad policy of inviting them some hey
remember that do you have that one clip
of the governor saying if other places
don't want you come here come to New
York we come to New York it's like no
listen you guys got to go this shit's
not working you got to turn back around
and go it is not going to be happening
what happened this is called bad
policies have consequences and no wonder
Governor Cuomo said people left I'm just
telling you and they're not coming back
we lost tax revenue from the rich that
went to Florida why do you think they
left to Florida why do you think they
did that right Tom when you hear
something like this what do you think
about first of all let's break this down
the 30-day rule he's talking about is
Airbnb people were complaining let's say
the three of you live in some tow houses
some Brownstones I made some money and
so I also have a place in Florida and I
come down to Florida for the winner I
start renting my Brownstone which is
right between in the middle of the three
of you as an Airbnb sometimes it gets a
little loud
sometimes people are smoking dope out in
front because it was five college guys
that were in town for the Army Navy game
you guys complained to New York hey this
Airbnb short-term rental crap has got to
stop okay great we're going to put the
30-day rule in here that if you're
renting it for less than 30 days that um
you can't do that and so they did that
in there to stop Airbnb in the city now
they're coming back saying the 4.2 4.3
billion let's put that into the pockets
of New York
and get around the 30-day rule in other
words wait a minute Tom's empty
Brownstone let's pay Tom but let's put
illegal immigrants in there the three of
you are going to go back to City Hall
and go wait a minute I thought we came
to City Hall that said Tom was running
it out to short-term rentals and crazy
people that were smoking dope out front
and these frat guys in town for Army
Navy games and I thought we put an end
to the short-term Airbnb because it was
affecting our neighborhood you're
telling me now that we stop that you're
going to tell Tom Tom's going to get
money not from Airbnb but from Eric
Eric's going to give me some of that 4.2
billion to put illegal aliens for short
term in my Brownstone ladies and
gentlemen that's what you just heard I
may be getting a little loud and
emotional here but that is what we just
heard you got to give it fired up you
got to give it to the Democrats BR like
what of course H how else are you
supposed to wait a minute we could be an
Airbnb with taxpayer money how else are
you supposed to treat your voters
Patrick how how are Democrat voters cuz
this is what these people are like you
got to kick out can you imagine you're a
father your kids at one time they're
going to high school in Brooklyn and
imagine the phone call hey your kids
can't come in uh tomorrow possibly for
the week and you're like oh my God was
there was there a gas leag was there no
no no people that don't belong in the
country have to go and sleep inside that
school because those are voter those are
future voters for decades to come for
for the for the party and if you think
about it I'm from Yankers New York okay
a lot of people tell oh Yankers ain't
New York shut up okay New York City has
fallen it has literally become Gotham
City C and you nailed it what did you
talk about how many times have you said
it bad ideas bad policies this is what
you get it's basically Gotham okay crime
is skyrocketing there's migrants taking
over high schools there's tunnels with
Jewish people just digging under
buildings looking the party dude what is
going
yeah by the way we'll show it at the end
you saw the video of it but what is
going on with New York City bro it used
to be the greatest City on the planet
not anymore bro you talked about bad
policies uh he says it all the time
right so this whole Sanctuary city
concept like let's just break that down
for a second that concept is being
exposed because essentially what it
comes down to is that it's prioritizing
the illegals over citizens it's PRI
prioritizing migrants over students I
get it that you need to have some
empathy but what happened to the rule of
law in this land does meanwhile uh you
see what Texas is dealing with millions
millions of illegals crossing the border
let a couple tens of thousands come to
New York City or net or marus Vineyard
oh no no no and no speaking English no
exactly so this is what Texas there you
go speaking of Biden right there listen
if you add up Obama and trump it still
wouldn't be as much as whatever last
three terms combined whatever this is
meanwhile Biden and Eric Adams the mayor
of New York I guess haven't even spoken
in a year they're not even on the same
page whatsoever I don't know what the
governor Kathy Hulk's doing out there
but it's a mess but when you're
prioritizing illegals or migrants over
your citizens look what what they did in
California they're giving illegals
migrants free healthcare meanwhile you
got veterans being homeless so the the
when we say it's all jacked up
something's jacked up going on this
country and just imagine being that guy
in New York when they're like hey here's
your new roommate Pico and he's like
helloo I I come to live with you what
what do you mean what do you mean yeah I
said I'm going to be a roommate on top
of your head what no we're going to put
a bunk ped what's I don't want it no but
but but you asked why Adam you said why
Pablo Honey
you but if but if you guys really think
let let's really let's bring it all the
way back is why don't don't fall into
this humanitarian oh with like
AOC and all these people oh my God going
to the border and hugging it and crying
and those cages that Trump built will
beer under Obama so let's let's go all
the way back it's votes it's 100% votes
and if you even respect Elon this much
and Rob is actually on elon's page his
last go to Elon musk's last let's say 50
tweets 40 of them are this in the USA
you don't need governmen issued ID to
vote and you can mail in your ballot do
you know what that is called cheating
that's why all these people are D oh by
the way that's so funny you're saying
that this data pull this one up zoom in
on this one this is very important you
know what this is zoom out a little bit
the in the first time in the history of
America never has this happened this is
the first time we have more illegal
immigrants coming in in a month than
actually giving birth to children look
at that wait what that's what that is
this is the the red is uh illegal
immigrants coming in the blue is number
of kids born in us on a daily basis oh
my God we have more illegal immigrants
coming in a single day single month than
kids being born in America we've never
had 225,000 people com in a month ever
the three records of the previous
biggest months ever were all broken
under Biden last month December 227,000
in the first 27 days 28 days yeah and by
the way outside of this it's very
important when you think about voting
Rob go to my last tweet I think it's a
second to the last tweet so yesterday
we're creating a creating a video on
illegal immigration which is going to
come out probably next week yeah zoom in
on this one look at this here 16 states
in America don't require any photo ID to
vote how'd that happen that's just a law
22 states require photo ID to vote okay
that tells you how many people have come
here 8476 million illegal immigrant
encounters since 2021 more than last
previous uh three terms combined I said
at this pace America will be Venezuela
ter three terms if something doesn't
happen to America by the way just a
question yeah okay can we google
something together Rob okay can you
Google something with me here Google and
Tom please let the audience enjoy it
without giving the answer we know you
know the answer just wait for this to go
through 16 yeah seriously which
president deported the most people
ever okay you want us to guess which
president deported the most people ever
matter of fact if you want to make it
even easier type in Google deporter in
Chief can I can we guess wait deporter
do you know the answer to the question
or no I think I think I know who it is I
think it's Obama it's Obama really
deporter in Chief no president on record
has ever deported more people what a
racist Barack Obama racist yeah well
Biden's making up for it on his term
right now is how you how is your VP but
let me help you out here what a racist
reverse those that's racist and and what
is going to be great is this you know
how perfect this is for a guy named
Donald J Trump he's going to say look
they called Barack Obama he should say
this cuz I know they listen to the
podcast chaos chaos yesterday 10 20
times chaos chaos chaos all you have to
say is we all know the goat everybody
talks about the goat greatest the goat
of deporting illegal immigrants in the
history of America is Barack Obama okay
do you know who call him the deporter
and- chief you can go to ABC News this
is not like Fox News type of stuff by
the way everybody left right center
everybody okay look at ABC news Obama
has deported more people than any other
president this is not ABC News the
porter in Chief okay the porter in Chief
right all Trump has say is come and say
look as somebody's who's fairly
competitive I'm going after the goat and
who's that Mr Trump he should say this I
know as you guys know I'm pretty
competitive but I I there is a goat I'm
chasing who's that Mr Trump there's a
goat I'm chasing and that goat is the
goat of deporting illegal immigrants wow
who's that Barack Obama deported more
people than anybody else matter of fact
go Google deporter in Chief tell that to
American people and you'll see who'll
come up kind in Barack Obama so when I
do become president and I do Deport the
people don't get upset at me I'm
following the footsteps of a Democrat
that you love and admire so much because
he's so gentle and awesome and welcoming
and caring and all this stuff he's the
goat of deporting I'm going after him
records are meant to be broken here I
come you know I know that they listen I
don't know if you cuz I watched the
Trump thing he took a jab at his shoe
too he did a jab at his boots I don't
know if you saw it last night but Adam
what were you going to say
did Trump trump yesterday mentioned the
boots oh he did do the boots thing the
boots well it just goes to show the
media will do their spin job because we
always talk about the difference between
personality versus
policy Obama's policy deported more than
any president of all time but it was
gangster on the surface Trump's
personality was the one that was
deporting all the people I think at this
point in our country you don't have have
to be a right-wing cook to realize you
know that wall idea we talked about yeah
kind of might want to think into that so
much so that you know is kind of slowkey
helping Build That Wall uh Joe Biden
yeah so you know walls aren't racist
especially when there's people flooding
into your country we'll build a big
beautiful door I agree in legal
immigration but at this point with the
with the people storming the the border
we're going to have to do something with
the only thing that they care about
storming is the capital they don't care
about the Border they just care about a
building that for I love you but here's
my question to you Adam what what is I
mean we're almost done it's four years
it's it's the damage has been done
that's that should be the the thing for
Donald Trump it's but where where where
are where is the left the voters the
people where is the outrage when you see
numbers cuz those charts aren't secret
he didn't he didn't dive deep into some
rabbit hole that is old all over the
Internet we're going to have over let's
say 16 to 18 by the time Biden's done
Trump said 18 where are the loud voices
of the Democrat voters going I know what
you're saying Adam it's like H they're
starting to talk shouldn't you be
screaming on the top of rooftops because
now the the mayor of New York is saying
guys we're going to get to a point where
you're going to have to take them into
your house what are we talking about are
you freaking ban so that's my thing to
all the Democrats out there all you
shitalking Trump people where are you at
where have you if it was Trump right now
forget it it'd be over but you guys are
just sitting on your hands with your
mouth shut because you can't admit that
this guy was the and didn't want
anybody to come in here unless they came
in here all right let's go to the next
story let's go and talk about fouchy
fouchy flipflop during the first 7-hour
session of grilling before house okay uh
so let's see what Fouch she did here
to nine Niner okay here we go during a
congressional hearing Dr Anthony Fouch
evaded more than 100 questions about
covid lab leak Theory and his ties to
Wuhan with house Republican accusing him
of plain semantics to avoid admitting
funding of dangerous research in China
that might have sparked the pandemic
fouchi acknowledged signing off on
millions of dollars and grants without
reviewing proposals exposing a lack of
oversight in his agency fouchi
commissioned a paper to disprove the lab
leak Theory and cited it during a White
House briefing without disclosing his
involvement he also backtracked on
previous claims that the US did not fund
gain of function research in Wuhan and
he couldn't confirm the existence of
oversight protocols for lab receiving
federal funds and uh there's more to
that but I'll pause right here Vinnie
thoughts well well first of all let's
let's he's a bureaucrat right he puts
the rat in bureaucrat I I I I think he's
a a despicable person if you've read uh
rfk's book uh the real Dr fouchy bro it
it'll blow your mind if you have time
even on audio book listen to it it'll
change your mind I know people in
California that would have those what
were those things called Robbie on the
lawn where it's just like him they that
that's the left's that was the left's
Savior but uh if you think about it this
hearing wasn't televised it's behind
closed doors the word that you read he
evaded 100 questions you don't get to
evade when it comes to millions of
people's lives you have to answer but as
we all know he is Untouchable okay zero
accountability you talked about this uh
what was this year's year of chaos last
year was what investigation but you know
what Patrick it went from your
investigation to zero convictions
investigate investigate investigate no
convictions no wonder why we're turning
into the year of chaos cuz people are
Furious bro this freaking rat he walks
around with security that's deeper than
the presidents bro I saw him walking on
that interview for CBS or whatever
there's guys with microphones there's
people on on the roof protecting him
because we know what fouchy is we know
what the hell what he did um and yeah
you nailed it you nailed it and by the
way this social
distancing I'm pretty sure everybody out
there remembers do you know how I knew
it was complete BS when I walked into
any airport every airport you walked
into every one foot was a 6ot social
distance social distance social but we
got on the plane everybody was just
mushed up on each other's faces I'm like
what does social distancing have to do
with anything it's all and now
the fact that he has to be protected
behind closed doors I think it's
people like that their feet
have to be held to the fire seriously no
accountability zero when when there is
uh you know they're talking about
retribution and you know massive success
is the the same as retribution there's
got to be an element of accountability
that's the only thing I'm asking for are
we going get it yeah I think I think
Trump has to he I there's is a part of
me that thinks he will or he won't
because you know he also brags about how
successful the war speed you know
operation War speed was I don't know if
he's going to go after fouchi play this
clip this is what Rand Paul said what
happened behind closed door testimony go
for it one thing that's consistent about
Anthony fouchy is what he says in
private is largely true what he says in
public is largely a lie when ask about
the MTH at that mask by a fellow
cooworker Sylvia Burwell he told her the
truth he said the masks don't work
because the poor are bigger than study
revealed that about the influenza virus
public he wears three masks and private
he tells his colleagues you don't really
need to wear one it's a same with
immunity it's the same with the vaccines
and it's really the same with gay of
function in private he said yes we're
suspicious that the virus was
manipulated looks manipulated and we
know they're doing gain of function in
Wuhan he describes it that's in a
private email in public to this day he
still denies that they funded any gain
of research gain of function research in
wuan it's all an
and but and hold on but you nailed it I
I I I I'm not disagreeing but I'm kind
of I'm on I'm on the fence where I'm
kind of upset where I'm like why do we
have to wait for a trump or whatever
these guys are in Congress I don't care
who runs the house it makes me more and
more by the day and Brandon says this a
lot guys he says it's a uni party
there's no such thing as Democrat
there's no such thing as Republican
they're on the same team because the
facts are the facts I don't care what
there's a part of that that I agree with
you because yesterday we're having lunch
and Tom
told us what happened with Bill Clinton
and Monica Linsky do you know how the
world found out about Monica Lewinsky
where everybody realized it's true was
it her friend told her to save the dress
that had the stuff on it okay and then
what happened with the dress and the
stain uh um Ken star went to the White
House took blood from Bill Clinton what
and that matched the stain on the dress
how did he get the blood from Tom he
managed to get a Federal subpoena and on
August 3rd they went in and August what
year this would have been 1996 or
something wow and then on August 19th is
when Bill Clinton went on TV and did the
do the accent please Tom what' he say
come
onx relations woman solely and
individually liable oh that's the one he
that's when he spoke to American people
I did have an inappropriate relationship
with Miss Linsky he should have just
been like because on August 3rd they
took the blood 4 days later they had the
DNA results that matched the dress and
Ken star was was going to leak it
there's all kinds of things that were
going on the late kenstar and Clinton
knew it and Clinton knew he was cornered
and that's when Clinton spoke by the way
you know why I'm bringing this up why am
I bringing this up because fouchy
investigation if they want to they can
find out you know you got uh uh uh the
the information with whose cocaine it
was at the White House if you really
wanted to FBI you could find out
yesterday do you have the clip on how
Hunter Biden shows up to court and this
looks like straight up out of a movie
like seriously this looks straight up
out of a mob movie and it's a
documentary about you know Gotti or one
of the bosses from the past watch this
go and play this for five
minut thank you Mr chairman uh excuse me
Hunter apparently you're afraid of my
words that's H Brighton just walked out
un untouchable untou
i' like to reclaim my time Mr chairman
bur their
bubble wow that's too bad they just walk
out oh and by the way that's like the
mob's biggest mob boss's son just says
you can't do nothing to me cuz I'm
untouchable going un he's going to be
pardoned at the 11,000 by the way there
was 4K cameras they're shooting a
document I'm not joking they're shooting
a documentary of him there was a camera
crew with this is all stage and it's all
it's all you know how disrespectful that
is nobody stops him it's all the show
dude it's all show play the clip of him
with the foxs the seven second one that
you just had I have a bad I sent rob a
really good one from behind do that one
after rob you please I'll answer your
question if you be quiet and let me make
a statement crack do you normally smoke
Mr Biden what he say what say what kind
of crack do you normally smoke I Sone to
legitimate question yeah what kind is it
good is it
Colombian look at this about where we're
at in society right now that's an actual
legitimate question one I sent what's
your crack preference H it to this is a
different angle look at this angle look
look at this this is oh it's one of
those we can't see I don't know why Rob
let's check to see what's going on with
this so we can fix it for next time you
want me to play it you got it oh is this
one with he asking ask she responds to
him well no do he looks look listen this
is this is report my name is
Heisenberg Hunter what's your favorite
type of crack
are you on crack
today he look he looks he's
like do you like shooting cocaine or
smoking
crack bro Hunter looked at him like does
your does your face does your face itch
sir so I think going to your point is it
it takes somebody with with brass balls
credibility credibility to because
because the system's not doing it it
takes one person to just give us that
little nugget that little dude can you
imagine and what a great advice from her
friend like Monica do not wash that
dress you save it save that dress cuz
you never know trip yeah you know how
many times Monica Luc is probably going
to go on she's like I'm going to wear
this there's stuff on that one you don't
want sa that one for the future think
about where we're at in society right
now that actual legitimate press is
asking the son the president's son
what's your yeah what's your preference
when it comes to crack I like the kind
that comes with some extra prostitutes
and some blow on the side yeah it's a
laughing stock and it should be it's
unbelievable that that is the the
president of the United States son is
shooting a documentary and he's a
crackhead but guess what the arrogance
of walking around like yo what are you
going to do nobody could do anything to
him just like they can't do anything to
uh uh Bill Clinton just like they can't
do anything to Dr fouchy they're on the
same team and they protect each other
and you can't do about it and
remember Hunter Biden is the smartest
man that Joe Biden has ever met those
are Joe Biden's words his crackhead son
is the smartest man he's well if you can
do crack and then also do a billion
dollar business deals you look at Elon
out there he's doing some drugs richest
man in the world that's levels to the
drugs like we talked about last
allegedly you know that elon's party you
can't even put elon's allegedly to
all the footage of him smoking C just
saying some great people tend to do
drugs sometimes there's different levels
to by the way if you show me proof I
believe it but guess what H Hunter just
go on X and put Hunter crack there's
videos of him in bathtubs and he's a
disgusting human being one I will say
one thing look at it look at it look at
the president the mo the smartest man he
knows look at that guy smart enough to
record himself doing crack and being
with girls that look like they're
underage he's a scumbag he should he
should be uh not seen in public yet he's
he's making documentaries and he's in
the middle of we got to hurry up I want
to go play football so I don't know what
you're talking true look at those teeth
right there that's his second set by the
way wow he probably smoked a couple of
them he smoked parmesan chees he said
off the carpet yeah so let's let's do
okay obviously let's do the last story
here yeah Rob see if you can pull up the
feud between Jason Whitlock and and uh
um Steen man why don't you you have the
Whitlock clip all the way at the top so
why don't you play the Whitlock clip
first something happen okay so obviously
we know C Williams you know came out and
he called out everybody and it became
the most viewed podcast of the last I
want to say 24 months that's been the
most viewed 40 plus million views
garnered over half a million
subscribers to Club sh Shay AKA Shannon
sharp and you know whatever you want to
say about Shannon sharp I thought he did
a great job with the interview sometimes
the gift of an interview is to ask the
question be quiet let the guy answer the
question and then let the market decide
credibility truth not right you do that
part that's what you know this is not
true he said this then hold Cat Williams
accountable I thought it was a great
interview but here's Jason Whitlock
inspired by Cat Williams go for it
Stephen A Smith is the Kevin Hart of the
sports media oh shoot there's music is a
plan what's going to happen with this
music turn off turn off the music stuff
oh my God you have to put so he's he's
comparing Stephen A Smith to Cat
Williams uh I'm sorry to uh uh Kevin
Hart that he's a plant and they gave him
money and the fact that he averaged one
and a half points a game in one game how
do you average one and a half points G
if you only played one game and your
knees all this other stuff snapped and
anyways this is Stephen a responding to
him and by the way Stephen A I've never
heard him talk about Jason Whitlock ever
me either I've not heard him and I've
listened to Jas to uh uh Stephen A for a
long time and I've never heard him so
heard him talk about Whitlock but go
ahead and play this clip did you tell
them that once the same article in dead
spin came out no this is not a this is
not a there's one where he says I'm
going to call I called my priest and he
called his pastor and said hey uh don't
look at me this week cuz I'm going to do
something that you've never seen yeah he
He just flat out called him out is what
he did so I if is this the one go I'm
played go ahead
Rob oh no more music I said that name
it's not a name I Ed
I normally don't do that but it's
necessary to do now that's music that's
LJ right there no no it's not that's a n
uh that's Nas that's e anyway so he go
ahead and tell the story what happened
what did Stephen A just said like like
listen you're going to make a video like
that he's like I called my friends I
told my colleagues he goes and I told
the people at ESPN shout out to what he
did here this is actually pretty great
he goes this is I work with you on ESPN
but this is my show and I have cart Blan
to do whatever I want on my podcast I
own my podcast I own my podcast he goes
I called my friends I called my family I
called my colleagues and he goes I told
my pastor and I told them listen you're
about to see a side of me that you've
never seen so just respect it I got to
go in and then after that I'm done I'm
not I I dude I gained so much more I
always respected him but I actually
didn't see him go in did you see the no
I don't think he has done it yet but you
know how they say it's better to ask for
forgiveness than permission yeah he's
not asking for nothing zero I don't need
your permission I don't need forgiveness
I'm going scorched Earth on this dude
I'm going in I can't wait to see what it
is Rob I just send you the clip Rob I
just sent you a clip to play with no
music where where it it this is the main
one that went viral if you want to did
you get it or no did I not send it to
you maybe I send it to myself hasn't
come through yet I probably text it to
myself but look in a situation like this
okay there's a couple things you need to
know we're not in this world right
meaning we're not in the sports world
where we know the the history the
politics the track record who got a
contract who took someone's job woodlock
used to be with who didn't he have a
show back in the days with ESPN or where
was he at he was an ESPN guy with Keith
Overman and all those guys right he's
kind of like from that era and then all
of a sudden there was a fallen out and
they said certain things about him but
play this clip here from Stephen A if it
plays okay there you go fantastic here
we go
and please do not allow this to be a
reflection on my character because this
is not how I act every
day but I mean it from my soul when I
say this is the worst human being I've
ever known wow wow damn I don't know of
another human being worse than Jason
Willock wow he is a piece of
wow he's the dude that's going to
have a funeral and ain't going to be no
PA
[Music]
might be two people to show up damn he's
that dude wow he is the absolute
worst and he lies and he incriminates
and he tries to set people up to fail to
Big up himself cuz he can't do it on his
own he had a television show he failed
he's had opportunities one time after
another he doesn't measure up and now
he's coming at the big dog and let me
tell you something right now I am the
big dog I ain't the only
one I ain't the only one there plenty
skip bis apologies to him too for
bringing up Jason whitlock's name in the
same sentence as him but we all know
what time it
is everyone knows I think in this space
he's the number one all the exec all the
they know what a piece of he is
wow and They begged me not to do this
but even my pastor AR Bernard said I'm
not happy about it but every now and
then we got to do what we got to
do promise
you the green Lord the green light from
the Lord I won't do this again I promise
you I know you cringing you didn't want
me to do this I'm sorry sis s it was
necessary he's a sorry fat piece of
a no of the worst order there's
your Cliff right there sorry fat piece
of Rob there it is oh my God that's
the title bro that's the title right
there oh my God and I want to make sure
everybody knows that he said mother
effort but they bleeped it out and I
said to Isaiah Thomas and I said to Dan
leard if you care anything about our
friendship don't ever call me about him
oh my God
again I'm a very forgiving
person not with him wow I don't care
what beef I had I don't care how many of
you out there that hate me whatever
former athletes all this stuff man
please I'm
sorry cuz I certainly don't hate y'all
we might have our differences from time
to time but ain't never
that this is the exception wow I hate
this
bastard not even far more than a little
bit by the way every time like the worst
human being
we got it you can pause it at this point
worst human being ever but I love how
like he goes back he he goes back to
like and I talk to this guy but you a
fat piece of but I talk to my
sister by the way have you ever heard
him talk like
this not one time and it's like what do
you think what do you think the only
people that he clowns worse than this
are the Dallas Cowboys and that's a
continual joke but this is ain't no joke
but here's Here's my thought a it has to
be really really bad for to do this
because as a Christian and you know this
and Tom I know you know this it I could
I I've lost my temper I can't even count
probably going to lose it today who
knows but to to to to S to know that
you're going to sin know that you're
going to do it and like I think like
listen I feel him trust me I probably
would have done worse but as a Christian
you calling your pastor this isn't a
good look for him though I mean for who
for for Stephen A Smith because the
eyeballs are going to be there obviously
but if you're going to be this Christian
guy and you know he is and you if you
call your pastor and even your pastor
goes hey go for it what are we talking
about like no no but have humility to by
the way to me I don't give two shits
about his religion he could be Christian
cive Jewish Muslim I don't care it got
personal and he's going right after
directly the fact that he called his
pastor and his pastor's like yeah you do
it dog I don't care about that here my
here's my question what you got to do my
question to all of you do you think real
talk with this hate if he sees him and
does he fight him that's who I am these
are two these are two 55y old men former
who gives a Jason windlock so fat
he probably can't get out of the out of
the house no but that's how I'm saying
what I'm saying is I don't give a
about none of that if I have this much
hate to another dude when I see you in
public it's on cuz these are just words
this is just Vinnie you want to step
outside bro Adam you're you want to step
outside it's not worth getting back too
dirty it ain't worth getting back your
too dirty but Adam you I love you but
you know what I'm saying though do you
think they're going to fight what do you
think about Whitlock I'm not a fan of
him from what I'm from what the
situation that we dealt with here I lost
all respect for him and when you're
supposed to be Fearless but all I'm
seeing from the guy is fear I don't
respect them I don't respect them man he
was walking a lot of he was walking
around the park remember he was walking
around the parking lot he was talking to
somebody on the phone all of a sudden
he's trying to cross Dixie Highway he
couldn't do it he's looking like an IL
alien trying to cross the border out
there completely confused and and he
just finally goes over some other
parking and calls an Uber or something
I'm like what is with this guy he is so
lost he he's trying to make a point he's
trying to I'm talking about Whitlock
trying to make a point on his own
podcast trying to say this but in the
middle of it you seem like he's got this
confused man that's full of anks that's
picking on people it's like I don't get
him yeah there's a lot of FWS you could
use for Jason Whitlock Fearless ain't
one of them I'd go fat
fluffy fake you know according to
Stephen A Smith he's an FN P OS we all
get it yeah Fearless ain't the word
though sorry Jason what do you think I
don't know I'm going to no comments on
this one what the hell you everybody
said what they said about him no listen
my experience with them I I I was uh
confused because if somebody's a gamer
and the whole situation was we were
going to have a podcast here and and we
already set our thoughts on that I don't
want to revisit that but in a situation
like this you know where I think
Whitlock was trying to have his viral
Cat Williams moment but nobody cared mhm
yeah he thought he's Cat Williams and a
market said bro you're you fat Williams
you're not you're not Cat Williams bro
yeah you you you're not Cat
Williams there's Cat Williams then
there's you are not at the Cat Williams
category no maybe he thinks he is okay
maybe he thinks he is maybe he's going
to leak other things maybe he's going to
bring up other stories great but you
know the the inspiration of him wanting
to be the modern day Cat Williams of the
sports radio not it it it fell horri
however in his uh uh credit he did get
eyballs Stephen A to respond 1% and you
know good for you if you're doing that
but it wasn't the right kind of respon
you want to get so anyways Rob have we
have do we have any big stories that we
haven't covered because I know it's the
weekend if we got another one we want to
do we can do it if not I got to go
upstairs I think we're good Yang do we
have one tomorrow or no podcast tomorrow
yeah we do with uh we mentioned John
Stewart earlier we have the Egyptian
John Stewart tomorrow Bassam youf oh
Bassam youf is here tomorrow fantastic
okay that should be that should be
interesting so gang tomorrow we'll do a
podcast we'll see you guys there
meanwhile remember there's an election
going on the most important one Adam Tom
and Vinnie man man me guys please vote
with your man vot for
I Tom doesn't need the money Tom doesn't
need a suit I have two suits I have
three vests I need your support God
bless everybody see you tomorrow take
care bye- bye bye-bye yeah
whatever